a
woman who was
she called in and she was asking she's
really close to accepting islam
but she was stuck she wanted more
clarification like what's the quran mean
what happened to jesus
because they say it's a historical event
that he ended up dying right they say he
was crucified but then the quran and
she's confused that okay if someone was
replaced an image of him and how does
the actual you know how do you like to
explain this situation
we have uh athar abdullah ibn abbas
which is really the
you know
that when prophet
is the one who combined this other it's
authentic
that when jesus peace be upon him
uh already felt like they are advancing
to come and grab him and and execute him
he stood up and he delivered a short
sermon this is what they refer to their
last supper you know where the wine is
but this is our virgin here
and he said
what will happen and he has to go and
all of that
but who amongst you
would accept that my likeness would be
thrown on him
now we're getting this from
from
abbas it's authentic the statement of
abdullah ibn abbas this is the company
who's
is the cousin of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam this is number one
number two the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam made very special invocation
for him he said allah
oh allah
teach him the interpretation of the
quran of the book
when you have
when we read abdullah
but but but we have to be very careful
because some of them are weak you have
to look at the chain of transmitters
make sure that one that you're narrating
is authentic
yeah yes the chin is authentic yes so
he's saying okay let's start with the
quran what does the quran say and then
he's giving ex to jesus of the quran
yes the tafseer of the quran here is the
verse
in in surah regarding jesus regarding
jesus in a chapter number four surah
nisa
i can give you the number later
allah is talking about the jew the
jewish community
who rejected the message of prophetess
because they disbelieved and they
uttered
allegation against maryam that she got
jesus out of woodlock that she did
adultery now yes she foreign yes
and because of their utterance
that we killed
the messiah the christ isa
the messenger of allah look at this now
they killed him not
they crucified him not
walekin should
but they were made to see that
that's where abdullah best comes to
explain
he said when they approached
the location where prophet isa was
hanging out with his disciples
he allah allah informed him that they
are coming to grab you to execute you so
he stood up and he delivered the sermon
short sermon
the last supper yes
but i mean there is no wine in there
right yeah so
so he said who amongst you
would sacrifice
that my likeness will be thrown on your
face
and you will be crucified in my place
and you will be my companion in jannah
the youngest of them stood up
now some people may have the right to
ask this companion just one second said
me o messenger of god yes he said oh
messenger yes
rasulallah not saying god says no no no
he said to them allah will raise me up
and
so that there is another messenger will
be coming and then i will come after him
to complete
uh his work yeah that's his second
coming but here it is
christians or anybody who hears this
has the right to ask
why did this have to happen this way why
this scenario because i tell you why
this scenario because with jesus have
been risen up taken up by allah
to the heaven without this scenario
the jewish community would have killed
all his disciples
because they would be looking for him
they are not going to believe that he
was taken up
right they don't believe he's a
messenger to begin with yeah so now
they're going to say where's jesus
oh he went up come on
so they're going to execute all of them
now who will spread the teachings of
jesus
after him
the disciples so that disciples have to
stay alive so that's why the jewish
community
has to be convinced that they gotten rid
of jesus you're getting that yeah that
makes a lot of sense so and this is what
happened you see when when when when
these disciples survived this hardship
they went around and they spread what
his teachings but around what around the
area where jesus was sent to you see
jesus was not a universal message
messenger
jesus was sent to many israel even some
you know in the new testament some guy
came from
the gentile asking him a question he
said no i was sent to the last
sheep of the house of israel i'm not
you know so
so the disciples stayed in jerusalem
you know to teach to spread his
teachings and they succeeded
they kept the fort for a while
until the self-claimed disciple pulled
you know some guy who you know
like the extreme surface kind of
experience he said i saw light you know
some people like in the muslim world
they say i saw light that's what he said
he saw a light he saw a light there and
somebody's sitting out there and telling
me but it's just like you know accepting
uh hitler after he persecuted you know
the jews well and then saying that he
got revelation would they accept him as
a messenger well look because he was a
bounty hunter look look what he thought
wasn't he yeah he was a bounty hunter
yeah he was killing the questions yes
yes
i made that example like let's say
hitler for instance was doing that and
which he was and then he came here
and that's what every christian should
should read in the book of corinthians
that paul
became so famous in cyprus and southern
italy
his teachings his distorted teachings of
christianity became so famous
that they invited them you know when you
hear that there is this famous scholar
in america let's invite him to come and
give a speech yeah but right now you
could go online and listen to some of
his speeches ah this guy is fake man
this guy is not real he doesn't teach
quran and sunnah then you cancel out his
trip but at the time he's a famous guy
who's walking around spreading them
but they don't know that he's giving up
distorted
the the doctrine of atonement the
sacrifice the the foundation for the
trinity so they invited him to jerusalem
to give a talk
in the book of corinthians the first
book
maybe you can look at i'll show you the
source there they chased him out of
jerusalem
he got chased out because of the
teaching what are you teaching this has
nothing to do with the people call them
out these are learned people those are
the learned people yeah imagine like
what a david pastor when you tell the
pastors as a christian
what does he say you know subhanallah
allah got this guy but i think one day
he's going to be a muslim in charlotte
the pastor yes he's a very nice man he's
he really he's really into it he keeps
coming back i think that's he's going
through a struggle jihad himself yes
right i think he's
he has so many followers
uh behind him and he wanted to be sure
that
subhanallah you know he comes and he
writes what i say yeah
i see him writing recording and even
after the hotmail he asked me you said
that word in harabi i didn't get it
you know
so what did you mean by that so
so maybe so go back to now this um
situation with paul what were you saying
so the bottom line here is here you are
you brought the the guy that the
christians now following
and he was face to face with the
disciples
of jesus
barnabas is one of the disciples of
jesus the one who saved you walked him
out come on this guy is going to kill
you man look about james his brother
jesus yeah
they chased him out what are you
teaching
what is this this has nothing to do with
what jesus told the pure message yes
you see he he he came up with with more
of a
uh idol worship kind of you know uh
formula and that is that is why it
received a very good uh acceptance or
the acceptance was very good in in
europe but but look at the end of the
day uh eddie you know uh this what i'm
trying to say is
you got two theologies evolving
progressing in in the roman empire
because palestine jerusalem at the time
was under the reign of the roman empire
actually the blooding to crucify jesus
was in between the jewish
community
and the uh
the emir the leader of of jerusalem at
the time who was appointed by the
reckless you know hercules so
um
you got those two
brands of christianity evolving
progressing
until they started clashing
they ended up clashing yeah
it's like that the sunni you know
very close to that you know so the the
the emperor constantine
constantine the emperor
the year 318.
his mom was more into the pole
his mother constantine's mother yeah so
he said i don't want this conflict this
religion the religious conflicts in in
my empire
he gathered all the christian
theologians from both
sects from both groups
in a place called nicaea
which is turkey now istanbul
it was his summer
break you know where he goes and spend
the summer
and he placed him inside the room and he
said you're not coming out until you
figure out who's jesus
is he the son
or is he just a messenger is he
subhanallah the
people
the pauline because now the politics
come to play
that's one of the most dangerous things
when the imperial power interfere with
faith and the whole environment if you
can paint the picture the whole
environment is a pagan virus
you see whatever goes
closer to paganism is easier sell yeah
it was appealing yeah you know like they
want to do now with you know the
imperial powers is working
hard now to actually influence islam you
need to know that too they want to
create that new brand of islam
you know and and people invest
governments are investing money
to come up with this abrahamic you know
that one
religion thing and all of that but they
don't understand that this is not going
to happen because
the uh
guidance is preserved you see in allah's
divine
knowledge
allah knew that after jesus there will
be another messenger who will come and
rectify things finish what happens now
so there so basically basically he said
to the uh
over 300 of them they were there
they said agree i want you to come out
with one religion not two
so what were the two they're deciding
one group is saying that jesus is uh is
a messenger
they're not claiming the disciples and
the teachings of the disciples he's the
messenger of allah he's the slave of
allah he came to call people to submit
to allah there is a day of judgment
that's what we believe in we believe in
now yeah that's us yeah yeah he is
muslims okay so then the other version
is what
the trinity he died for your sins
yeah so the other one is the doctorate
just that alone tells you something yeah
right you see what i'm saying just that
alone that there's the debate with all
these heads at that time the beginning
now
of when all this happened what that
should tell the intelligent person like
hold on advisor even is the debate by
the way this is history
these things are history it's not
something like that we're making up yeah
actually we got this from their own
books yeah
their own narratives now you can try to
explain it away as much as you want but
yeah you know it's straightforward
common sense why is there this debate
now why is there this group there's the
group they're in there right they're
saying no these earlier sources you know
the earlier groups the ones closest to
jesus